hi I'm Chris I'm working at the
distributed robotics lab in csail with
Robert Cashman and Daniella Russ
basically the labs developed a soft
robotic fish
right now the mechanism is there we have
a hydraulically powered soft tail fish
there's been a lot of interest in soft
robotic fish in the past because
the um the flapping tail motion is
actually very efficient underwater
compared to a traditional propeller on a
submarine you get more efficiency like
just power use and higher
maneuverability and like fish can turn
in a fraction of its body length whereas
the submarine has to turn to slow down
and turn into this Big Arc so fish are
much better in under like complex
underwater environments there's been a
lot of research and interest in
like exploiting that mechanism in Roblox
one thing that makes our fish novel is
the hydraulic Tail
as opposed to a Pneumatic tail which is
a more slightly easier to implement but
also not as uh you don't get as much
duration because you run out of air for
example it's a few other problems with
the buoyancy control as you're losing
air
so hydraulic tail is ultimately probably
a better system which is why we try to
use it
um what I'm working on is this uh the
software and the visual surveying and
things like that we're trying to build
the autonomy of the fish uh so far uh
all the existing robotic fish have been
just tele operated so they're just like
stupid fish that you have to like like
drive around like remote control car we
want to make ours autonomous so
our software right now uh the dream is
to get it uh
to lay a foundation that's expandable
and modular so it's easy to add on
different layers of autonomy and
different modes of moving so for example
we could have like pre-programmed paths
or some kind of computer vision control
motion you can add another thing as you
go we want to make it uh very easy to
add on different behaviors that's kind
of what I'm working on at the moment
hopefully within the next
few months
we want to the first level of autonomy
will be this visual servoing where
you're so you're following some brightly
colored Target like a life jacket
you can use computer vision with a front
mounted camera on the fish
to pinpoint where that Target is in the
scene and if you assume that like here
that your direction of motion is
straight into the center
then you want to correct that so it's
pointing at the Target so you just type
it in offset and put that into your swim
controller adjust like here up into the
left and that way you stay pointed the
target
um there's actually a lot of like
subtleties with the control you have to
deal with like how fast you're going to
make sure you don't like pass the Target
or like lose side of it things like that
that I think will be interesting to
explore as we go with that
um and then once we have that we want to
build a more like
dedicated navigation techniques
underwater localization for example with
acoustic positioning
um we could use for like Waypoint
following things like that
so there's really a lot of potential
with this platform we're just trying to
build a platform that's easily
expandable and can be used for further
research on
fish control the fish movement and other
water controls